[Music]
one of the ways that I try to figure out
if I'm an optimist or a pessimist about
something is to look at as much evidence
as I can find and look at trends so
that's what I want to do here we
familiar to a lot of folk in this
audience a fact with technology jobs and
wages so first question what's going on
a complicated phenomenon here is an
overly simple answer my answers are all
going to be over simple simplifications
hopefully not deeply wrong over
simplifications hollowing out the
workforce in America and most of the
rich countries in the world this was a
phenomenon really nicely documented by
our MIT colleague David autor who Eric
mentioned earlier today let me show you
a representation that David drew that's
my favorite picture about what's been
happening for the American workforce
over the past couple generations all the
jobs that existed in America in 1979 and
he lined them up from lowest paid the
highest-paid and then what he wanted to
do was look at future time periods and
see how the jobs moved around not in
absolute numbers but in market share
we're recreating proportionally more
well-paid jobs or proportionally more
less well-paid jobs and what he was from
1979 to 1989 this is what happened the
red line is no change in share so if
you're below that red line these were
the kinds of jobs that lost market share
over that time period the job everything
above the red line gained market share
of jobs over that period so even though
it doesn't quite look like this on the
graph the area below the red line is
always equal to the area above the red
line and what you see is a really happy
phenomenon from 1979 to 1989 most of the
jobs we were creating were right there
you know 40th 50th percentile and above
we were creating middle class upper
middle class upper class jobs in America
we were proportionately losing share
down at the bottom half of the wage
distribution this is fantastic
what watch that bulge of the jobs where
we lost share
watch what happens to that bulge as we
move forward in time because there's one
pretty clear trend that bulge starts to
move in one direction the job of share
being lost starts to go upward in the
wage scale created a bunch of fairly
lousy jobs I got that job creation down
low middle class is doing pretty well
things got weird between 99 and 2000
basically the only jobs we were creating
were lower middle class and lower class
jobs and that job loss was pretty widely
distributed and no one was doing all
that well in the most recent years for
which we have data that phenomenon is
accentuating the only thing that's
changing is that the 80th percentile and
above is doing pretty well this
corresponds to the data that Jeff just
showed on what's been happening to the
top 10% of the wage distribution so this
is I love this representation it's it's
a very clear picture of what's been
happening to the US workforce over time
lots of things have been happening to
the US workforce over time this is my
favorite and most clear picture about
what's been going on so we got this bar
bell-shaped economy where there are
gains up top and gains down a fairly
lousy low pay primarily service sector
jobs and the classic American middle
class has been getting hollowed out the
US only phenomenon absolutely not
here's a pretty nice graph about 16
European countries a different way to
show the same phenomenon three bars for
each country least paid jobs middle paid
jobs high paid jobs the phenomenon is
entirely consistent in every one of
these countries the job loss has
happened right there
in the middle we hear a lot about why
this is going on is this mainly because
if we're exporting all these great
manufacturing jobs to China absolutely
not we are manufacturing exporting
manufacturing jobs to China and that's
responsible for something but let me
show you what I think is a really
elegant refutation of argument no
picture of US manufacturing value-added
what gets lost in the debate very often
the u.s. is a manufacturing powerhouse
China recently took over the number one
position we are the number two
manufacturing country in the world our
manufacturing output is greater than
that of
Germany France Italy and India combined
pretty steadily every non recession year
we keep turning out more stuff we keep
turning out more stuff with fewer and
fewer workers overtime so the red line
there is the total u.s. employment in
manufacturing that peaked in 1979 and
has been heading down with a couple you
know flows but heading down fairly
steadily ever since this is purely a
productivity story this is purely an
automation story it is not a
globalization story ah no what is the
cause what's going on here again to
oversimplify hopefully not too much the
phenomenon that's been going on is the
large-scale automation of routine work
what we need to keep in mind is that the
American middle class
this large stable prosperous middle
class was built on the back of routine
work the fiftieth percentile
American worker does not have a college
education has never had a college
education this is lower than college
educated routine physical work think
about a employee on an assembly line and
routine cognitive work think about the
payroll clerk in that same Factory and
work on this let me put up his
conclusions he's not a technology
scholar primarily so when he says stuff
like this I take it pretty seriously he
says look what technology is really good
at is substituting for routine
repetitive work both cognitive and
physical his work is beautiful it's
really thorough and he says look we've
taken into account low skilled
immigration we've taken into account
globalization we've taken into account
these other explanations they are not
central to the phenomenon to the finding
that's going on here so the American
middle class is getting hollowed out and
it is the technology that's the main
driver of that okay well why isn't there
mass technological unemployment this was
what Keynes was predicting in 1930 we
don't have mass unemployment the US
unemployment rate is about four point
seven percent it's about four point
seven percent and has been below five
for coming on a year now there is a
combination of things that explain this
number one it's good old-fashioned
economic
growth there's nothing that created jobs
like a growing economy combined with
flexibility and mobility in the labor
force
unfortunately the kind of mobility we've
been seeing is downward mobility so to
underscore that point about the central
importance of just economic growth this
is the top line there is US GDP per
capita that's growth and then the red
line there is how many jobs there are in
the country these two have this
incredibly tightly coupled relationship
the reason the gap between those two is
growing is just plain old productivity
we have an incredibly flexible workforce
this is an OECD ranking of different
measures of Workforce flexibility the
OECD is the rich countries Club we have
probably the most flexible workforce
across the OECD so when situations
change our labor force can reallocate
itself more quickly than other places
other countries have a higher official
unemployment problem than we do in law
in part because they don't have as
mobile a workforce but the problem is
the mobility has been primarily downward
again to redraw the picture
we're hollowing out right here and we're
creating right there the mobility is
primarily going down what that means one
more line on that graph thought this is
what it looks like so that bottom line
there the one that's flat lining is 50th
percentile median American household
income flatlined about the turn of the
century and we really haven't made up
all virtually any ground since then so
there actually is mass unemployment I
want to underscore underscore something
mosha I said earlier there is a
community in the states that is
experiencing european-style levels of
unemployment and it's exactly prime age
American men this is what's been
happening to their labor force
participation and labor force
participation means you're either you
either have a job or you're actively
looking for one so these days about 12%
of prime age u.s. men are not employed
and they're not looking for work they're
deliberately sitting on the sidelines of
the economy like you can imagine this is
pretty tightly concentrated among the
least educated American
so the participation rate among people
with at least a college education is
declining pretty slightly look how bad
the drop-off is is you go downward in
educational attainment what happens as a
result of this some of the consequences
I think are pretty straightforward and
we've talked about them I want to
highlight a couple other consequences
that we haven't spent much time on today
and that as I've been looking around I
find more and more important over time
if you want to say one thing though it
is really hard to say with any
confidence that anything that I'm going
to talk about is due to technology is
due to unemployment is due to labor
force conditions social phenomena almost
always have what what social scientists
call causal density in other words the
anything you look at has lots of factors
causing it there's this rich mix of
stuff going on all the time so any one
to one argument about robots are causing
the following is just way too simplistic
with that caveat here are some other
social phenomenon going on that I find
interesting and let me preview them in
general kind of scary
the first one is mortality I like a lot
of us know one of the most positive
phenomenon we've talked about it a bit
in in any decent recent time period is
that mortality death rates for any
demographic group that you care about
anywhere around the world have been
going down they've been going down
really steadily and quite quickly with
one exception that we just learned about
I believe last year Angus Deaton who won
the Nobel Prize in susan case wrote a
paper where they documented a counter
phenomenon that we were not aware of and
I find kind of scary it is rising
mortality among middle-aged whites in
the United States so those two declining
lines are african-american mortality and
Hispanic mortality that's that happy
phenomenon they're dying less often
middle-aged American whites are dying
according to this estimate the death
rate is slowly increasing other
estimates are quibble with that just a
little bit but Deaton in case said the
difference between those previous
downward trends and the flatlining that
we're seeing on that line if you if you
integrate over that area the loss of
life is not true
it's about equivalent to the AIDS
epidemic this is a big deal in mortality
why it's going on for three reasons Jeff
mentioned the obesity epidemic and yeah
that's actually a tiny contributor to
what's going on you can look at deaths
from diabetes that's the red line
trending up a little bit there the
increase in white mortality is due to
three causes chronic liver disease
suicide and acute alcohol and drug
poisoning people are killing themselves
quickly and slowly I don't think that's
that too broader way to say it and I
can't say it any more politely than that
this is a pretty serious social
phenomenon so we talked about well-being
and the fact that you don't need a job
to have well-being this is a pretty
scary counter example this is the
opposite of well-being in addition there
are some lovely recent work looking at
other social conditions and what's been
going on charles murray is a is an
interesting guy and a very careful
digger in data and he wrote a book
called coming apart a little while back
where he characterized these two
archetypal American communities an
upper-middle class one that he called
belmont and a lower middle class one
that he called fish town and he just
looked at a bunch of social trends over
a pretty long period of time in these
two and he kind of divided them into
these two archetypal communities so we
looked for example at what's been
happening to divorce rates and it turns
out upper-middle class Americans are not
getting divorced residents of Belmont
are not getting divorced any more often
than they were 30 40 years ago meanwhile
residents of Fishtown divorce rates are
skyrocketing the number of kids being
raised with both biological parents
again it's very high and it's kind of
flatlined for decades in Belmont in
Fishtown
that rate is dropping down below 30% in
the most recent years it's a precipitous
drop in just one or two generations and
then finally both on Fishtown were white
by the way because Murray was tired of
being called a racist so he looked at
what's been happening to imprisonment
rates oh no one in this room is not
going to prison Belmont is not going to
prison and crime rates in Fishtown
incarceration rates in Fishtown have
been rising in a way that that is really
really surprising
and then finally just in the past couple
years there have been a some some really
nice work done by sociologists who even
before the rise of Trump decided to
spend some time in these white
working-class communities and we can
talk about books that came out that I
found really informative one of my
favorite ones
is a book that just came out early last
year called the politics of resentment
where a sociologist went around and
spent time in these white working-class
communities in Wisconsin and she just
found this overwhelming sense of
grievance and resentment and a feeling
of betrayal by the BIOS this
constellation of factors that clearly
matter a lot to a lot of people so I
look at some of these social numbers and
I have trouble telling a happy story
about them when I talk to Silicon Valley
utopians I kind of get this idea that
let's hate late that what they kind of
say is let's hasten the day when there's
no more work because then it will be all
Burning Man all the time and I just I
don't see that in the communities where
work is actually going away over and
over again so I was trying to articulate
that this is an actual problem that we
need to worry about in this community
needs to worry about
I completely agree with Andrew my
number-one concern for this weekend is
what's been happening with the
intersection of Technology and jobs and
wages so I was trying to crystallize
that and the best I could come up with
earlier this year is something I'm
calling maccabe's passion and it's that
if current trends continue the people
are going to rise up before the machines
do this caution has two really powerful
virtues number one is it fits in a tweet
number two is that it's got a fantastic
visual aid so that's our incoming
president on the left and that's Nigel
Faraj the leader of the brexit movement
in the United Kingdom Moshe I agree
we're already seeing symbols of
discontent that are altering our
political landscape are going to alter
our society for at least the next four
years so second to last question well
okay are things going to get any better
is there any reason to believe that
these trends are going to reverse and
that we're heading into a happier future
I take a lot of heart from the kind of
optimism that Daniela puts out there and
Marc Andreessen articulates when we talk
to him and their kind of thing look this
is there are some problems with this
period we're living through but calm
down the lot of people have been talking
about mass technological unemployment
all these horrible things that come with
automation for 200 years for 200 years
the economy has grown the workforce has
grown average incomes has grown things
have gotten massively better I
completely agree with Jeff for a lot and
a lot of people we are under estimating
that engine of prosperity and meaning
out there history is going 200 years of
industrial history are going to repeat
themselves the patterns going to
continue there's another view that says
no the thing that we're under estimating
actually is technological progress and
especially this burst that we're all
excited about and that a lot of us are
contributing to the power of modern
technology is putting us into a
different regime this time actually is
different and the trends that that we've
seen here are are an early indicator of
this different period that we're
actually in and if you believe this the
natural conclusion is that some of the
trends these trends are going to
continue and some of them are probably
going to accelerate personally I believe
that so finally what should we do about
this and I'm gonna follow Jeff's lead
and actually make stuff up out of whole
cloth and what I'm gonna make up as a
Venn diagram that tries to categorize
the solutions that you hear based on the
audience that you're interacting with so
the three circles on my Venn diagram are
economists technologists and politicians
and I want to fill this in a completely
idiosyncratic subjective and non
scientific way a few politicians like
trade wars nobody else likes trade wars
I think Trump found the one economist
who has a PhD and teaches in a
university in the country who thinks a
trade war might be a healthy thing for
the American economy nobody else really
believes that a couple other things that
politicians are fond of where you find a
bit more commonality with some other
constituents Jeff did a very nice job of
articulating an economists view of
lowering income tax on people and the
idea that bounty will happen as a result
of that some politicians like a minimum
wage a couple economists do but in
general Akana
don't like artificial ceilings or floors
on prices they seem they tend to think
that perverts the proper working of
things there is some commonality between
what economists like Jeff mentioned a
wage subsidy for lower income workers we
have one of those in the United States
it's called the Earned Income Tax Credit
both Paul Ryan and Obama have said it
should be expanded most of the
economists that we talk to you agree
pretty strongly with that
in contrast a lot of technologists that
I talk to are I believe overexcited
about this notion of a basic income this
idea we are a wealthy society we can
afford to distribute cash to people
let's do that I agree that we should be
helping people earn more money but when
I look at the graphs that Murray put
together about the social woes I
honestly struggle to think how any of
them would be fixed by dropping money
out of helicopters in these communities
it just absolutely does not compute to
me I like work because of the dignity
and the value in the community that come
along for him work in our last book Eric
and I put a quote from Voltaire him that
I continue to fall back on he said work
saves us from three great evils boredom
vice and need of those three the
universal basic income only takes care
of nee need I think it's by far the
least of the three evils so where is
there some commonality the economists
and technologists that we hang around
with our adamant about the need to
liberalize immigration the fact that
we're keeping out some of the most
talented and tenacious people in the
world who want to come here to build
their lives in careers it's just it's
Kafkaesque it's nonsense and then the
idea that we have a couple large
companies that are giving working people
without advanced skills the opportunity
to learn live earn a living by driving a
car or by opening up rooms in their
homes to rent out to people and we're
putting all kinds of roadblocks in their
way I find that ludicrous if we're
interested in helping people earn a
living we should be interested in
companies that help people actually earn
a living and then finally if there
anything in that happy intersection I'm
being a little bit optimistic about this
I think there are a couple things
Trump has talked about infrastructure
we'll see what happens there but you
have to go a long long way before you
find an economist or a technologist that
I've talked to who doesn't want
better physical and digital
infrastructure and then finally we've
heard over and over and over about the
importance of educational reform I agree
with that I think it's probably
necessary I do not believe for a second
that it's sufficient so I apologize for
that quick drink from a fire hose but I
think evidence is always helpful in
these discussions Thanks
[Music]